c'était l'ambiance des grands jours à
nfle le château l'équipe locale qui
évolue en régional 2 recevait le Red
Star leader de national à l'occasion du
5e tour de la Coupe de France dans les
10 premières minutes les deux équipes se
rendent coup pour coup mais sur cette
action les quatre divisions d'écart se
font sentir le Red Star marque les ver
réussiront ensuite à inscrire deux
autres buts avant la pause 3-0 on sa que
sur les matchs de coupe le danger c'est
si le match dure un petit peu on peut on
peut se mettre en difficulté on a vu que
c'était une équipe aussi qui a pu
parfois nous mettre êre en difficulté
donc faut qu'on soit absolument très
concentré sur ces éléments là et ça
passe par un très très bon début de
match et ce qu'on a fait c'était c'était
important pour nous au début on s'en
sortait quand même bien au début on les
a on leur a fait un bon pressing qu'on
avait travaill entraînement comme j'ai
dit mais ensuite comme je dit c'est
tactiquement tactiquement cétait un
petit peu audessus faut dire la vérité
et voilà au retour des vestiaires NF le
pont chartrain met plus d'impact et se
met à réveillec ce but inscrit à la 55e
minute par siikou Diara mais le Red Star
accélère et inscrit un nouveau but 4
minutes plus tard puis un autre à la 72e
minute score final 5 à1 on Savit il étai
fort et bon ça fait du bien aussi de
jouer contre eux c'est une bonne équipe
le meilleur pour eux et franchement
c'est bien aussi dans l'expérience de
pouvoir jouer contre une équipe comme ça
c'est une belle équipe sincèrement c'est
ce que je disais je pense qu'il y a des
joueurs qui peuvent jouer aessus je
pense au numéro 10 au numéro 9 on a vu
des joueurs qui ont qui ont défendu leur
maillot et ça c'est c'est une grande
fierté pour eux ils se sont bien
comportés je pense qu'on a vu un bon
match de football cet après-midi
nefleopon chatrin devra se replonger
rapidement dans le quotidien du
championnat de régional 2 les ivinois
joueront ce dimanche 22 Octobre à
domicile contre Paris-
X